life in Liverpool amidst the biggest
fall in living standards on record these
full-time working mothers share their
stories the cost of living crisis yeah
what would that mean to you
absolutely nightmare it's ridiculous
especially when you wear you're striving
to do better and as I said I'm working
myself I do whatever hours to come while
the kids are at school because I
couldn't even afford childcare before
the current cost of living crisis
worsened by brexit the pandemic and war
in Ukraine many people were just about
managing but soaring inflation energy
costs food prices and wage stagnation
have left working people reeling this is
what it means to live in a poverty trap
that's the liver for me is just
struggle constantly you choose in
between as yourself said like gas and
electric
um at the end of the day if I didn't
work that month
we're pretty much going to starve
according to new research by the charity
Action for Children almost 2 million
children in the UK could be trapped in
poverty and hardship because at least
one parent faces a barrier to working or
taking on extra work and some 440 000
children are in poverty despite at least
one parent working full time of that
number a quarter of a million are in
poverty despite living in a household
with two parents where both are in
full-time employment like all traps the
more people are forced to struggle
holding down multiple low-paid jobs 24 7
or perhaps they can't work because
they're full-time carers the more
painful the more challenging life
becomes and Charities argue that the
best way out of this trap is to provide
more money for children in need and to
lift the current cab on social benefit
what we need the government in to do is
to say we acknowledge that people face
barriers to taking on additional work
and we need to try and break down those
barriers sometimes that might be higher
pay sometimes might be supporting people
into work where they are able but
sometimes it's saying we acknowledge you
can't work as much as as much as you're
able as much as it would take to lift
you out of poverty and we need adequate
Social Security benefits the
international monetary fund predicts the
UK will be the only Advanced economy in
the world to contract this year
recession is on the horizon and the
government's response is a new era of
financial austerity and public spending
cuts the more people need help the less
is seemingly on offer and for these
working mothers the government's message
that work always pays seems a little
more than a myth with the job should be
able to afford and enjoy a good life or
at the minute we're not are you proud of
what you do
I'm doing my best Neve Barker Al Jazeera
livable